was removed from Twitter he was removed
from making fun of Oliver Darcy he
doesn't understand that Alex Jones used
dead children for politics you pest
prick I'm sorry fraud fraud fraud
[Music]
fraud you've all been very good boys is
that true um for the most part the good
news is I can tell you about a gift
early this year yes I was confused by
winds mullet this is for the whole
family so you can have a great Christmas
a big
check this Christmas celebrate the
spirit of giving with us as we give back
to the community that has meant so
much join us for the special event this
Thursday it's a louder with Crowder
[Music]
[Applause]
Christmas
change what I
know
[Music]
CH good morning no sip for you I don't
do sips I'm sorry I like to sip but I
just don't do it on air it's something
that's weird for me Stephen is going to
be preparing to do shortly that
interview that you saw with Piers Morgan
uncensored 400 p.m. eastern time on
YouTube make sure that you guys tune in
and watch that yeah uh it's going to be
it's going to be a bit of a spicy
meatball today we've got people getting
ready to be offended on all sides and uh
one Englishman getting ready to have his
booty handed to him um so let's jump
into it for today the rundown we've got
the pope blessing uh gay couples not gay
marriage he's not saying gay marriage
but gay couples I have issues with that
that don't worry I'm going to bring in
the Protestant church as well everybody
will be equally offended but in the
hopes of making things better you know
who's making things better this
Argentinian Fireball down there Malay is
actually transforming the government
doing what he said he was going to do
fantastic Japan buys us steel fedman
doesn't really like that but let's
figure out if that's actually a good or
bad thing and then mug Club you get to
hear a little bit about Texas uh where
we're going to actually be able to
arrest uh people who are here in the
country I don't know illegally can we
all do yeah I guess we could be
deputized I don't know handcuffs I show
you why do you have handcuffs Tim what
let's dive deeper into illegals really
why is there fur on them there's not
anymore and make sure you have your
chats ready to go I know you're going to
have questions you may even be
frustrated with me a little bit and
that's okay put on a helmet today is the
day you need to Eat Your
Spinach not sure that spinach and
helmets really go together but whatever
you're you're going to like it and
you're not going to like it and trust me
I will be fair I understand I'm not here
to bash any particular church at all I'm
just saying don't do what Protestants
have done and I'll tell you why I mean
that but when you hear this lovely tune
oh oh oh huh yeah I Like It Raw oh
boy Josh finstein how are you sir I'm
good good morning everybody good morning
Josh you're going to be Friday and
Saturday December 22nd and 23rd
in Columbus Ohio yeah this weekend with
JP series we're going to hang out with
JP that's awesome he had a thing he had
a little bit about toilet paper somebody
asked him about it and he's like is it
okay to put toilet paper like rolling
away from you and he's like yes that's
like trying to hand somebody a bottle of
water by throwing it across the room
yes that's good I appreciate that and
look because we're going to get a little
SP I probably I mean maybe there's not
going to be a whole lot of opportunity
for this but maybe there is but if at
any point you see
this head on over to rumble make sure
you get over there there and do me a
favor go to rumble to begin with I mean
if you want to start at YouTube for 5
seconds just to mess with the algorithm
and make YouTube think that we are
absolutely never ever ever going to stop
being a thorn in their side because we
won't um then go over to rumble I'm fine
with that it's a good way to do it piss
them off then
leave it'll make everybody happier I
love it all right so uh first thing
we're going to get into today and uh I
had not seen this video I don't know how
uh he's going to justify this just watch
it with us New York city mayor Eric
Adams he was asked to
describe New York and like what made it
great and he makes a lot of mistakes but
there's one glaring one see if you can
pick it out Mr Mayor we've come to the
end of what was a very eventful 2023
right so when you look at the totality
of the year if you had to describe it
and it's tough to do in one word what
would that word be and tell me why uh
New York um this is a place where every
day you wake up you could experience
everything from a plane crashing into
our Trade Center to a a person who's
celebrating a new business that's
open
uh is that the brand of New York that
you're trying to promote is this real
life does this happen I think I remember
that in that Frank sinra song I was New
York I don't know it's like the the
missing verse from that song yeah boy
he's yeah planes are crashing
into the buildings I don't know that
that I just I was offended at first
because he said one word and he says New
York and I'm like okay that's two words
but I understand fine and then he keeps
talking I'm like okay this guy doesn't
get the rules at all and then he pulls
out you can see a plane flying into
buildings I forgot about all the issues
like it's a feature he said like like
how exciting the city is one day you
could wake up and there's a plane
crashing and all your neighbors are
dying and then the next day a business
opens that's that exactly Clos down for
Co isn't that sweet but but all the
cleanup building the businesses sprouted
up to clean up the mess so that's good
for the city hey maybe a helicopter will
crash
next a crane or a plane into the hson
another crane will fall down they crane
fall down so much all the time or it
just be more you know Mayhem and murder
on the Subways but look imagine like
you're
Hiroshima
and you're like you could wake up and be
incinerated by a nuclear bomb and then
visit our beautiful castle we've got
everything in we've got it
all Moscow don't come to us we'll come
to
you it's the
stupidest C these nicknames yeah like
what is their what is their plan to
advertise you know like tell me about
New York you can watch planes fly into
our Towers don't
do that who elected this guy New Yorkers
God I mean that's the stupidest thing
I've heard about what about Jerusalem oh
my gosh
oh Jerusalem for it
come come for the temple stay for the
buses blowing up I don't know something
like that it's it's just you don't put
it on the card come for the Music
Festival stay for the Hamas beheadings
that's not what you're going to say what
in the world is wrong with Eric Adams
it's the stupidest thing I've seen from
him and that is saying something such a
New York thing too he's so confident he
is New York New York yeah with other
things that I'm going to say and I love
how the guy didn't jump in and interrupt
him he's like well he's the mayor I said
one word but he can say as many words as
he holy crap he said Towers really he
said our Trade Center too yeah I really
wish the camera had been on his face
when he did that he I mean he just like
yeah see the iso of the guy yeah like
you're dying inside and you can't show
it to the public like anyway but look
we're we've got a number of different
topics that I think are going to be fun
to jump into today uh and and look I I I
want to lead this off with the question
of the day what are your thoughts on the
pope deciding to bless gay couples
comment below let me know um I know that
mug Club chat you guys are going
absolutely nuts with this be nice to Kim
I told her to put on a helmet uh but I I
want to set this up uh really quickly
anytime a Church doesn't matter what the
church is anytime a church does
something that represents a large group
of people I am necessarily going to have
problems one way or the other with a
policy not people right sometimes it's
people a lot of times it's policy most
of the time almost all of the time I
don't have a problem with the people
that church represents the the people
that are going to the church and so
let's just make some clear distinctions
like we do with the Chinese Communist
Party versus the Chinese people right
I'm not attacking Chinese people I'm
attacking the leadership of that country
and the bad decisions that they make
China is assho
exactly true I didn't say it he said it
I said it so just understand that when
I'm talking about this segment I'm not
talking about Catholics right I
understand that you guys can get very
frustrated by being targeted and that
people misconstrue what the Pope says
all the time I completely understand
that look I I have my issues I've been
very very transparent about some of the
issues that I have with it but not
because I hate Catholicism I went to
Notre Dame like had these issues these
disagreements these questions with
Catholicism for a very long time totally
fine you guys have questions for me
about protestantism totally fine
everybody's on the same team here right
we're all trying to push in the same
direction but this is going to be
difficult because I don't understand why
this happened okay let's jump in and
another move that some would label
Progressive I think it's pretty
Progressive right not good that's I
don't know that that's a good thing Pope
Francis will allow Catholic church
leaders to officially bless
samex couples Francis is formally
allowing priests to bless samex couples
in what is being called a Monumental
change for the Roman Catholic Church the
Vatican today included this in a new
document that insists uh people seeking
God's love and mercy should not be
subject to quote an exhaustive moral
analysis to receive it but the document
reaffirms that marriage is a lifelong
Sacrament between a man and a woman and
so it's not like priests can bless
marriages or civil reunions look I
understand that that's what people are
saying right I think some people out
there are Mis kind of representing what
the pope said that he is now blessing
gay marriage he's not blessing gay
marriage he's also not forcing anybody
to bless anybody he is allowing it which
is a different thing okay so now that
I've set that up correctly let's read
what the vatican's news arm put out
yesterday when two people request a
blessing even if their situation as a
couple is irregular we'll come back to
that irregular it will be
possible for the ordained minister to
consent however this gesture of pastoral
closeness must avoid any elements that
remotely resemble a marriage
right however they all still end up in
the same
place I don't make the
rules some good let me I'm going to make
a couple of points here and uh one of
the points is is sure to make people
frustrated and I don't mean it to but I
want you to think deeply about this to
receive God's love and mercy I would I
would I would say that the church can't
ever get in the way and it's not the
only way to receive God's love and mercy
um throughout reading scripture I I
think it's pretty clear that we can
receive God's love and mercy in a lot of
different ways and it doesn't
necessarily have to be through the
church so when it talks about that and
then that clip said having to go through
an exhaustive moral kind of uh uh
Reckoning so to speak speak I don't
think you have to do that either right I
think anybody can come to God and say
God I am a sinner the problem is that
God Jesus when he walked the Earth never
allowed for somebody to come to him and
stay where they were he was Winsome and
loving but honest and that is something
that we have to keep in mind here so
there's two different types of blessings
um I was looking this up before to make
sure I didn't mess this up but
invocative and constitutive and
constitutive is the one where it's
basically blessing like a person or a
place or something like that where it's
like to like a holy purpose right like
so this is that's the higher form of
blessing yeah invocative is basically
like when you bless your child but here
it comes with no change in condition
required that's an interesting take uh
on this what do you mean that no
changing condition meaning like it's not
saying hey you have to acknowledge this
or change that to receive this blessing
right so I'll give you a comparison but
I I just want to set this up with one
more thing the Church of England
actually came out and just one day ago
officially blessed or maybe a couple of
days ago now officially blessed their
first lesbian couple the church is in a
new place and and I'm really pleased
with the decisions we've made that once
these prayers are formally commended
later this year the faithful stable
Christian couples in a civil marriage or
a civil partnership can if they wish
come to church and that you know they
love for each other in that relationship
can be acknowledged celebrated and the
couple can receive blessing that's never
happened before I'm pleased about that
but at the same time I think I need to
say I'm not standing here full of joy
because I think the debate has has
clearly revealed divisions in the church
over over these issues and those
divisions cut across you know we're
we're a family and when families
disagree it's always
painful yeah there's a reason look again
I don't make the rules but look we can
only imagine what Sunday morning at
church will look like here in a few
years
we're a family that was worse than I
thought it was going to be no shirts or
shoes Reed there you go all look and and
all welcome 100% can if somebody comes
in who's having an affair and comes and
and the church knows that that this man
has a wife and he walks in with his uh
weekend fling hand in
hand you don't think that the church
should be like whoa whoa whoa brother
what what's going on what do you doing
that that's the same kind of thing like
I don't understand why this is any
different but I'll get to a bigger Point
here in just a second but look I don't
think it's any
coincidence that a volcano erupted the
same day the pope decided to bless gay
couples that's the official headline too
that actually
happened it was a real thing we saw live
look at the Vatican actually that's
Iceland I'm just just
kidding but look I so I have a problem
with what the church has said here and I
have a problem with when I say the
church read that to Pope the pope is the
head of the church your rules again not
mine and 84% of you out there have a
favorable view of the Church of
Catholics just 47% have a favorable view
of pro of Pope
Francis you have an issue in this ruling
I I understand where people are coming
from when they say look we want people
who want to find God to be able to find
God yes but God never left people in
their sin and saying something isn't sin
that God says is sin is not loving it is
not the way that you approach this
situation beating somebody because
they're gay is also not loving that's
not how you approach the situation have
I clarified on both ends where we
shouldn't be good now in the middle when
people come to God it's not an immediate
like you have to be good enough you
don't go and take you know wash your
hands before you take a bath I get it
you don't have to go and clean up your
life before you can come to God that's
fantastic here's my issue how do
churches end up in apostasy how do
churches go
astray little by little by little and
you know how I know because I'm a
Protestant and I know what you're
thinking right now you're thinking oh
he's going to talk about how Martin
Luther left the church because of these
issues yes he did and we'll get to that
another time but what I'm talking about
is we are making these mistakes already
in protestantism don't follow our
example my
issue isn't with homosexuals or
homosexuality it's with the church not
standing on the principles of what
scripture says you can't change what
scripture says I'm sorry if it's
inconvenient to tell people truth do it
as best you can in a loving way and
represent God to them but we have
churches right now that say
homosexuality is not a sin
you can't change scripture like that
that's leading people astray and giving
them a form of godliness but denying the
power of it it talks about that in
Scripture that is a wolf and sheep's
clothing God doesn't want you to do that
this is how problems arise don't be
hateful welcome everyone let everyone
experience the love of God but do not in
any way shape or form convince people
that sin is goodness
because you will have a big problem and
guess who has a the guy upstairs he has
a problem with that
my I worry for people because I want
them to hear truth in church that's
fantastic I want gay couples who are out
there who believe in God to have an
opportunity to find out who God really
is to understand the full counsel of God
and understand what sin is and what it's
not but if you allow stuff like this to
go on in your church how far down the
road is it until there's so much public
pressure put on that now you have to go
a little bit further and a little bit
further and a little bit further and
then 10 years from now you look up and
the church doesn't look anything like
what you think it should and that 47%
view of Pope Francis being favorable
among Catholics drops to 10 or 15% and
then you have another Schism this is why
we have all of these things is because
one person looks out and says hey this
is what the Bible says you guys are
doing it a little bit differently here's
my final question for you and then we're
going to move
on anybody out there who says that Pope
Francis was doing this to try to welcome
gays into the church to make sure that
the church had open arms for everyone
every sinner in the world including
people who are having premarital sex
Yours Truly
sinned I repented from that and turned
from that that's the difference not
everybody does I understand that
churches are full of Prosperity Gospel
in protest I understand
that you want to be open Pope Francis
why
couples yeah why not just individuals
why not just people yeah you could have
solved this problem in a much different
way instead of celebrating gay couples
instead of blessing them sorry the the
the the Anglican the the Church of
English way what does the blessing do
because I I want to know if if does if
you don't get a blessing do you still
get to go to heaven yeah so this is if
you're a s and you get to you repent you
get to go to heaven this is not anything
like that this is basically something in
Catholicism where you can get a blessing
from somebody like the priest right
somebody a part of the church basically
it's a method of getting love and mercy
from God accessing that like and I
understand it's like blessing your child
or something like that you like it bless
you there's blessings throughout
scripture Jesus blessed people right God
blessed people I understand that but
when the church is doing this in this
way like it means something it's an
official thing it may not be the
official thing it may not be the highest
form of blessing but it's a thing and
it's not a right it's not a part of the
marriage right I get that and you're
right it's a slippery slope slippery
Pope slippery Pope there you go I like
that po pop Frank look I you guys
comment below reach out to me on Twitter
G Morgan J that's fine we can have a
conversation about this but please don't
come at me with I hate the cath Catholic
Church I do not I love everybody out
there who professes Christ as Savior and
God as God fantastic but that doesn't
mean we can't have conversations about
disagreements okay if you guys are still
interested in winning a truck because I
think a truck is kind of a nice thing to
win cash still it does come with cash
$110,000 but in quarters oh I all in the
bed the entire bed of it's all it would
fit really it's 10,000 quarters that's a
lot of quarters it's like 40,000 of them
can you jump into I'm not good at math
but are you close I think I'm exactly
oh look at you I'm better than that at
math
Tim brand new Ford Raptor 2024 Edition
$110,000 in cash go to Crowder shop.com
grab yourself some sweet merch don't
worry there's not like a you know
Catholics or bad boo shirt or anything
like like that on there I promise or
Protestants like I said I went after
protestantism too cuz sometimes we make
really bad
mistakes speaking of a guy who so far so
good hasn't made mistakes yet
libertarian Javier mle was sworn in as
argentin
new
why did he like did he feel like he was
going to burst into flames if he
actually touched the Bible because the
Bible is I think that like blue purpley
thing I don't know I'm color blind sorry
guys he reached over towards it he's
like a no but he said whatever he said I
swear but didn't touch it why touch it
no I don't know Spanish I guess in in
Argentina you only have to hover hand
the Bible
really I guess so so baptism is just
getting close to water got it
okay a week into his job as El
Presidente he is already making huge
moves he has do you remember that video
that we talked about where he did the
aera thing he did it in real life he cut
the number of Ministries in
half by removing Livestock in
agriculture transport Public Works
territorial development I'm not
sure what that means
culture science tourism environment
women's Affairs
a perfect I'm sorry women we didn't end
with you on purpose it was just the
natural order of things I already also
women I already well no no you don't get
rid of Argentinian women that's a bad
idea no 34% of government jobs were
eliminated the number of jobs he got rid
of half the Department's 34% of the jobs
now look if you were doing one of those
jobs this isn't time for celebration but
you shouldn't have had it to begin with
the incoming economic Minister Luis
Caputo h i stuck the landing on that
sorry if you speak Spanish Caputo said
mala's government is quote facing the
worst inheritance in the country's
history that's one way of putting it he
also took other steps to reduce spending
and curb inflation he devalued the peso
by 54% he stopped all government
advertising Public Works contracts were
canceled kind of sucks for those guys
and he stopped payments in the
provinces and I don't really know what
provinces
actually yes who hello there um I'm here
no it's s here hi everybody we're live
Sam what's up you scared us well I'm
sorry but this announcement can't wait
um I was inspired by President M's uh
announcement and so I'm implementing my
own series of reforms around uh the Lal
with Crowder offices oh jeez all right
whatever yes I know you guys like snacks
here but snacks are a Roy wait what's a
Roy yish for
a so I know you guys like pulling pranks
pranks are ay come on Jewish jokes
they've all been done ay they haven't
all been done Merry Christmas got plent
more a no no no no no you can't take
Christmas from me Sam not on my tur you
short Bes speckled ysh grch it's not no
happy hanuk carwan either I
mean
a a freaking
Sam a man that guy's got a you're an
Sam excuse me can't take
Christmas try more upset about snacks or
Jewish jokes come on they haven't all
been done we talked about this yeah I
got a few you want to hear
them how many many different people of
Faith do we want to piss off
today in anybody want to talk about
scientology yeah
Mormonism can I get G to piss everybody
off I every encounter I've had with
Mormons has been peaceful and polite
they've been very helpful mostly
peaceful yeah I just don't like the
theology uh or their shirts what's up
with that and their mountain bikes are
always on mountain bikes these Mormons
Jehovah's Witnesses both of them
I here we go you're
confusing all right so look I love what
mle is doing down in Argentina so far
this is exactly the kind of thing that
we thought he would do and look we've
seen people campaign before and say
they're going to do all these great
things and then get into office and have
trouble doing it or completely doing a
about face and be like ha fooled you
just wanted to be a politician in power
and I would like to come back with that
to the United States Donald Trump has
talked about cutting the bureaucracy
cutting debt and he tried to do a lot of
reform in the United States to give him
credit but look again it's not always
convenient it's not always easy to hear
there's frustration I want to hold
people accountable to improve not to get
rid of not to you know hurt but he tried
to reform us but the government workers
refused to implement Trump's policies he
didn't get rid of bureaucrats fast
enough and so a lot of the policies that
he put in place didn't actually take
effect and do what he wanted them to do
January 2017 to January 2021 hint that's
Donald Trump's presidency national debt
increased by $8 trillion the first three
years without Co I know that's what
you're saying is co was a big player in
that absolutely was $4.5 trillion of
that was Co without Co $3.4 trillion
that's a lot that is a lot of debt to be
adding on when you want to cut debt now
I know that's a hard thing to do there's
a lot that goes into that and you know
who else knows it's really hard to cut
debt who's that Joseph robinet Biden the
former vice president himself $4.7
trillion added to the national debt so
far seems like he's trying to make some
kind of push to records there and Trump
he he made a a big deal about draining
the swamp um the last time and he's
making a big deal again in 2024 he needs
to follow through and he needs to get
rid of the people that stopped him from
being able to do that some of the
leaders excuse me that we had in power
just wouldn't do what he said I don't
think that happens this time around what
do you
think um I think people are scared yeah
yeah I think that some of these people
they want they want to they want to like
the bureaucrats yeah yeah they want to
do they want to they want to do what
they're supposed to do yeah well I I
think I think this time around like the
bureaucrats he kind of knows the game a
little bit more the first time around he
had to learn even though he was a
businessman even though he was Brash
even though he had the ability to go in
and just say what he thought and didn't
care what people really you know thought
about him I don't think he fully
understand the the corruption and the
rot in the system and so to be able to
take it out he needed a little bit of
experience so I'm I'm hopeful that this
time around and predicting of course
that this time around he'll be president
the swamp doesn't want to be drained no
no so they're going to do everything to
prevent that very apparent swamp's going
to swamp they like being swampy they do
they like being swampy swamp monsters
they are they are I hope he drains it I
hope this is not just a another
political promise that's broken I hope a
wall gets built yes it's also a
different Congress this time around it
is yeah no different people are around
he led the way a little bit so there's a
lot of people that have kind of followed
the trail that he's blazed so to speak
right and and gotten into positions of
power within Congress and throughout
government that might be useful and very
helpful for Donald Trump but it's like
hey just do it build the wall it's a
great idea don't make Texas have to make
it a crime like we'll talk about with
mug Club but look Javier Malay um he's
cutting government and bureaucracy in
Argentina mostly because there I believe
and and research look this up for me if
you can uh what's the interest rate I
thought it was like
143% or some ridiculous number yeah it's
inflation is massive the interest rate
is massive maybe I'm I'm converting
those to maybe it's inflation that's
143% interest R 140 plus% it's insane
the amount of issues that Argentina has
right now and look he's made some good
moves we'll see how that plays out it
may end with a a bloody coup who knows I
hope not I'm just saying when you fire
you know giant sads of government
people can get a little pissed off that
you did it but hopefully I think it's
firing lazy people I don't think they're
going to be uh out there trying to work
hard to in the environment people people
aren't lazy that go into environmental
sciences no just kidding of course I'm
going to go down this list again here
I'll give you I'll give you a few
women's Affairs
people come on that's like gender
studies I don't I don't understand what
women look if if women are being like
you know mistreated almost as if Islam
was in charge over there fine I
understand it you would need like you
know somebody like hey we can't do that
to people that's that's terrible it's
also interesting too not all these
things are eliminated the uh the
Departments are eliminated and dissolved
but they're being right they're being
Consolidated probably you're right
Ministries right like the services
aren't going away they still care about
tourism it drives economic growth in a
lot of countries and so of course that
maybe just gets pushed over into another
thing but you got you got a culture
science I don't know what what do
Argentina contributed to science I have
no idea but we'll see how this goes
right um I think it's a good move I look
at the fine I'm just saying like tell me
what you've done I don't know you've got
an Argentinian football team that's fine
you've got the Andes Mountains right
next door great what have you done
science wise oh great mints they do yeah
I think that's about it okay but I like
these moves and we will see what Donald
Trump does in the United States so
comment below do you think Malay is
going to be able to turn Argentina
around yay or nay look if you don't care
I understand that but you should these
kinds of things are happening in other
countries right now again we're seeing
this stuff play out in other places
let's learn from their mistakes not have
to make all of them ourselves it seems
like we love doing that and I hope
Donald Trump when he comes into office
he fixes the problems that we have here
in the United States and he calls this
out we'll see I'm hopeful so and Gerald
from uh oh they got the percentage from
research key interest rate 133%
inflation 140% well at least they're
catching up to one another thanks
133% can you do me a favor one more ask
and I'll move on to another story and
we'll come back to it later on but just
do me a favor in the United States I
think we had 7% mortgages or 8%
mortgages recently and people were
freaking out about that because of what
it at can you do 133% mortgages please
thank
you I'd just like to see what that is
let's not put that out there in The
Ether that's not that's uh yeah you're
going to never pay it off like your
children's children have to sign on the
dotted
line yeah your your shanty it's it's a
payday loan Che wasn't cash check
cashing places oh my gosh those people
are the worst that means at least one of
those guys jumped off a building
anyway it was in a documentary I'm just
saying it seemed like a fitting end he
was living high off the hog and you know
raping and pillaging and decided he
didn't want to
anymore that's good just going to let
that sit
there
that's okay all right problem
solved
yes Lan Mar yes that's right whatever
it's called the people that promote it I
don't even know what it is anymore
paycheck cashing services anyway Brian
Kalen Mr off limits is on Tuesdays on
mug Club he's going to be at the comedy
zone in North Carolina December 29th
through the 31st make sure you go and
show him some love if you are in the
Charlotte North Carolina area or if
you'd like to make a drive I hear it's a
fun drive to make over there and see Mr
Brian Ken and see his show on mug Club
senior off limits there okay yeah New
Year's Eve shows are good by the way
they're really cool about to say it's a
really cool experience a special day the
31st yeah it's if you're a comic
headlining you're always working New
Year's Eve unless you are that makes
sense good enough to not have to do it
but
uh I'm not uh but no always you work in
New Year's Eve I didn't mean to offend
you no it's always a good show they they
usually have the comedian do like a
toast and they'll do a countdown at
midnight and you know that's awesome
give out champagne sometimes and stuff
like that so that's a cool you ever you
ever is like one of the jokes ever doing
the countdown early just just screw with
people like like not like an hour early
so they're like yeah I'll go ahead and
go home but like 14 minutes early or
something like that I don't know if it's
a that's happened before you mean in
Louisville Kentucky last me guess we
were doing the countdown and we're like
won we all cheered and then someone's
like it's not even midnight the crowd's
like it's not midnight pull out their
phone well we're already playing the
song Drink the champagne drink up we'll
drink for 15 more minutes let's end the
year you know what that's alome that's
something that I've never understood
like let's end the year with The
Hangover and start the new year like on
the couch it's like hm and people bang
their pots at night could be a better
way to do it I don't know but I don't
know do something
productive like jump off of buildings if
you own a check cash just kidding just
kidding he didn't do that on New Year's
nobody would do that what a great
resolution all right let's turn to
Steel the US steel uh company has agreed
to be sold to Japan's nepon steel and uh
oh this guy John fedman is absolutely
not happy about it I'm standing on the
roof of my home right here in bradic
Pennsylvania right across the street
from the Edgar Thompson plant and I just
have to say it's absolutely outrageous
that they have sold themselves to a
foreign nation and a company can't do
that steel is always about security as
well too and I am committed to doing
anything I can do from using my platform
or my position in order to block this hm
wow how did the stroke make him smarter
he's D Federman is one like right-wing
common away from an FBI investigation
yeah just it happened to sudden be like
hey John we know it's you we can see the
hoodie and
shorts hey Mr carart we heard you talk
about China too it's five degrees by the
way when you select backgrounds to talk
about industry Smoke Stacks right here
not the best look because we're like we
probably ought to get rid of those in
the first place anyway I'm not sure I
know it was cold there and it was
probably mostly steamed but hey it could
be killing people down the street too we
don't know it's Christmas he's like how
am I supposed to wake up in the morning
and and after my stroke and smell smoke
all is it smoke I'm smelling or am I
having a stroke do that keep the smoke
please I need smoke I can't live without
smoke but that's the Hostess plant
smells good the Hostess plant oral reden
boers right down the street they make
ding-dongs and I'm a ding-dong there we
go yeah they can't string sentences
together either who let him climb on his
roof I don't know but unfortunately he
doesn't climb he's such a big
I'm on my roof I'm like how'd you get
there who let you do that but well look
to your point unfortunately he couldn't
actually find his way down afterwards so
his family had had to make him part of
the Christmas decorations and so it just
became a fixture yeah hey still here
guys
I I imagine Federman on his roof it just
makes me think of like a mob with
pitchforks and fire going get the
monster no don't look at
me or listen to me either one of those
things nepon steel outbid the others
that were bidding for this and it's
funny to to see that other people were
bidding for this because you when you
see their bid amounts you're like they
weren't really bidding uh they out bit
others with a $4.9 billion offer which
according to the stock price and the
company valuation is 142% premium not a
bad deal if you're going to buy a
company pay 142% more than it takes to
buy all of their shares but sometimes
that happens that's Argentina money
that's Argentina money you can buy the
whole country Malay will probably sell
it to you for a deal
a that's what US deal win win a a that's
more than two times the next highest bid
though they see value in it way way more
s Mark was 10 billion do I think
something like that so that it's more
than twice that's insane that's a lot of
katanas yeah well you know
anyway so here's the thing why are
people upset steel is a national a
matter of national security right we've
talked about this before having steel
production is very important here in the
United States it's used for everything
cars ships constructions uh construction
Wars right you got to build a ship
you're going to need some Steel World
War II the United States made more than
half of the world's steel now here's a
big problem with people being worried
now about
steel China they lead the world in
production more than the rest of the
world combined oh we're for
behind India and Japan Japan has less
land to put steel mills on and they
still produce more than us wow this was
a huge huge problem I I spent some time
in after Notre Dame not against
Catholics not Catholics bad we we have
the the Hitler bad thing this we're not
doing a catholic's bad thing I'm just
saying it's not but I lived in Cleveland
and all these steel mills and and the
production a lot of that stuff was
already shut down this was in 2002 2003
that was a problem back then but Donald
Trump tried to change that he put a 25%
tariff on Chinese steel to try to
protect Industries now you can argue
whether you think tariffs work whether
protectionism is a thing that you want
to dive into but at the very least you
can see that it has been a problem for a
while and Donald Trump understands that
problem maybe the potential loss of us
jobs is what's pissing people off
Pennsylvania Senator Bob Casey had this
to say I'm concerned about what this
means for the steel workers and the good
union jobs that have supported
Pennsylvania families for Generations
whatever for the long-term investment in
the Commonwealth and for American
industrial
leadership we haven't LED in industry
for a while you have to understand this
for the him to say the good union jobs
that have supported Pennsylvania
families for Generations are you going
to stand in the way of progress probably
not are you going to be a protectionist
are you going to be somebody who just
tariffs everybody else what about a a
country who basically just says we're
not buying anything from anybody else or
no other companies can buy our stuff and
and and have plants here you can't be
like you know a Hyundai or a Honda or
anybody else that's producing stuff here
in the United States employing American
people even though it's a foreign owned
company I understand why there is some
nervousness here but should we really be
upset about this is it really a threat
well according to uh X I think we're all
getting comfortable with calling it X
now yeah it's fantastic it is DC Dro
tweeted I'm with fetman on this one
don't allow the sale of us steel to a
foreign country this is a national
security risk we should have already
learned our lesson when we outsourced
nearly all our antibiotic production to
communist
China well respectfully I disagree it's
not a it's not not selling to the
country though it's not like it's
communist China where the the companies
are we're not Outsourcing by the
government you know what they did they
bought the steel mill
here which at the very least means they
have to employ people here in this
economy and they have to help the
communities here steel production won't
move to Japan in fact they agreed to
keep nipon steel agreed to keep the
headquarters in Pittsburgh could have
gone anywhere else they chose Pittsburgh
oh I can't wait for new Steelers uniform
I know right Japanese Steelers uniform
it's going to be like it's going to be
like one of those anime books right it's
going to be awesome I don't know I never
was into anime but it's going to look a
lot better than some of these uniforms
but look they decided to honor the union
contracts as well I don't know why they
did that but they did and maintain the
US steel name
those all seem like really good things
to do seems like a good business
decision really it doesn't seem like uh
anything more than that or malice keep
the keep the employees happy yeah keep
the brand
name you know what you know what US
steel was going to do go out of business
a that was us steel they were going to
try to sell to somebody else who was
going to pay half of the value for it I
think that's a problem because they
obviously don't see as much potential
typically when you buy companies like
this or you know you kind of shut down
parts of it you uh you streamline it
that's what they like to say
streamlining is basically saying hey
we're going to cut cost you know what
the main cost center is for PE people
we're going to cut people you're the
cost sorry you're going to get cut out
of this deal so they're going to honor
the union contracts Union should be
fantastic you know they should be very
happy about this they're going to
maintain the name the name they're going
to keep it in Pittsburgh that seems like
a pretty good deal I understand being
worried about foreign countries
companies companies that are in foreign
countries not the countries themselves
buying up things like this in the United
States especially when people say well
it's a national security issue well
China makes pretty much all the world
steel right now anyway or at least so
much of it that we're buying a lot of it
from them so why isn't that a national
security issue that we've solved I would
hope that our national security isn't
being protected by um steel plant
workers too well that's that's also true
I don't know where the risk is yeah I
think what people are saying is if we
need Steel in a pinch we don't to depend
on a country we could be at war with to
provide said steel I understand that but
that's with everything should we not
have smartphones or should we have to
put everything here on okay so should we
not use chips what if China takes over
Taiwan and now we don't get access to
their the
microchips most of our way of life
changes if China shuts that off
shouldn't that mean that you're
absolutely 100% for protecting Taiwan at
any cost and like Vive ramaswami
proposed even though it was kind of you
know Silly to say that we could do it in
the the time frame make sure that we
have those capabilities here but what
about this in a time of War if Japan's
not on our side we take it back if we
have to we can just seize the assets
it's in the Constitution Article 1
Section 8 Clause 2 I think look and it
does remain to be seen what npon steel
will do with the operations and you know
all the jobs and everything but us steel
hasn't been thriving for a very long
time and it's time to acknowledge that
it's not a new issue at the Granite City
mine in Illinois local steel worker
President Dan Simmons noted this we know
what US Steels operations plan was for
Granite City and it wasn't positive so
myself and members I represent in this
community were ready to embrace a new
owner that would that would like this
facility we make grades of Steel that
nobody else in this country can make us
steel didn't take advantage of that okay
so you have a problem with management
that's new but he's right nepon steel
they've had investment in in the US
since 1984 starting in West Virginia in
2008 nepon steel took full ownership of
the Wheeling nepon plant in fby West
Virginia and this is exclusive to us
these are our people going out and doing
what no one in the media apparently has
done we reached out to the philby mayor
Dave Vogal sorry if I get that wrong
Dave Vogal for comment and he had
nothing but praise for the company
saying they are a tremendous corporate
citizen we couldn't ask for more since
1984 they've had this company there us
us steel I I don't know who they bought
it from but nepon steel has been
operating he also noted that how
Wheeling nepon donated hundreds of
thousands of dollars to initiatives like
disaster relief construction of local
baseball fields Community function
look nebon steel sees a lucrative Market
here in the United States cheap energy
costs growing
population economy that seems like it's
trying to to get turned around at some
point with a new person in office that's
that's fantastic kind of betting on the
future a little bit bit increased
infrastructure spending those things
sometimes if it's more taxes if it's
more debt I have problems with that I
understand but maybe they can succeed
where us steel hasn't and here's my
question for you final question on this
would you rather it go out of business
would you rather it be bought by
somebody who can't see the value and
can't turn it around they may be wrong
in their bid they may go bankrupt we'll
see but I would rather some come in that
sees the value and sees an
opportunity than to have this just shut
down anyway and leave yet another town
destitute because everybody depended on
it on the steel meal for their work I
don't know that's just
me look I've enjoyed hosting we've got
one more story that we are going to do
today Josh and I are going to have a
little fun with this one but this is
going to be for mug Club if you are not
a member of mug Club you get this
fantastic girthy mug you also get the
book beautiful differen is from now
until I believe Christmas maybe maybe
we'll extend that to the end of the year
if you join mug club uh $89 Ann annually
go to louder with crow.com mugclub you
get this show you get extra segments of
this show and full additional show most
of the time here with ID with Crowder
you get our undercover unit which is
fantastic Alex Jones Hodge twins Mr guns
and& gear you get Brian Ken you get Nick
doollo the OG you get all kinds of
additional thing so go and join today
and let your freak flag fly over the
holidays Stephen will be back tomorrow
but remember that interview is coming up
here in just a little bit uh Piers
Morgan uncensored 400 p.m. eastern time
on YouTube make sure you watch Rumble we
love you YouTube go piss on
[Applause]
something
[Music]
yeah